when images of five-year-old on Randolph
nice were released the world was shocked
to see the young Syrian child sitting
calmly as blood dripped from his ashen
head but who actually saved Ahmad on the
young boys story ignited another round
of discussions about how best to help
Syrian civilians but what seemed to go
and mention however was the group that
saved on the road the white helmets the
Syrian civil defense also known as the
white helmets is a grassroots
organization made up of 3,000 volunteers
the group carries our rescue operations
following airstrikes by the Syrian and
Russian militaries you can watch video
after video on YouTube of men in grey
uniforms with white helmets rushing into
disaster zones across Syria's rebel
territories arm Ronda Lucia's home in
Aleppo was friend in an airstrike by
either the Russian or Syrian government
planes the white helmets arrived on the
scene and pulled Imran out from
underneath his flying house mehran's
brother wasn't as lucky
he died from injuries sustained in the
attack just two days later since 2012
activists have called upon the
international community to save Syrian
civilians from government aerial attacks
the white helmets were born out of those
unanswered calls in early 2013 and have
received at least 23 million dollars in
aid from the US Department of State to
date the group says it saved 60,000
people and they've been nominated for
the 2016 Nobel Peace Prize but ordinary
Syrians have been at the forefront of
providing services to fellow citizens in
different areas for more than five years
activists often set up local
coordination councils to help govern
their neighborhoods villages and towns
in the absence of state institutions
drawing upon their own skill sets that
kept schools and daycares running and
work to keep Hospitals and Clinics
supplied to the best of their abilities
they have also opened media centers to
keep the world informed on what's
happening inside Syria and bring stories
like Iran's delight risking their
personal safety they continue to
document the number of killings human
rights violations and unlawful
imprisonment by all sides during the war
their efforts have ultimately created an
alternative to both the Syrian state and
political opposition and given all the
good they've managed to accomplish why
are we doing more to help them
[Music]